in the last couple of weeks we've been  building out the space into a space that  works for us it's still a work in  progress but it did really get us to  start thinking about how we want to work  and how we want to grow as a business  [Music]  one of our main priorities was having a  really large work surface for each of us  we use it for filming and product shots  and for making models and I also want to  be able to lay out arcd drawings and  sprawl out when I'm doing research and  for some reason I'm always finding that  I'm needing more space on my desk  and once we have a full-time local  person working with us  [Music]  this beautiful solid wood desk will be  yours